direction azay sur cher à présent à la
rencontre d'un couple de tours en joue
désemparés face à la justice
un chantier qui tourne mal des
procédures administratives et des aides
à rembourser
philippe et sylvie gadin son passé de
victime à coupable aux yeux de la loi
aujourd'hui il en appelle à la
solidarité de chacun avec une cagnotte
en ligne lucas chopin cela devait être
leur petit paradis
en 2009 philippe et sylvie entreprennent
d'aménager leur comble pour leurs
enfants
rapidement des malfaçons ressortent le
plafond s'affaisse la maison risquent de
s'écrouler
il faut autant ménagé au sous-sol en
justice le couple obtient dédommagement
de 88 1000 euros de la part du
fournisseur de bois et de l'assurance du
charpentier à l'origine des travaux ou
non avec une maison étayé commence à en
avoir marre d'un côté qu'on a eu
l'argent si lyon fait les travaux entre
temps les coupables font appel et la
justice leur donne raison
le seul coupable et le charpentier mais
déclarer insolvable suite à la
liquidation de son entreprise c'est
sylvie et son mari qui sont condamnés à
rembourser ce qu'ils ont touché 88 1000
euros plus des intérêts pour un total de
91 mille euros
au départ on a été des victimes puis ben
maintenant on est des coupables
je peux vous dire qu'on dort pas tous
les jours d'autres très mal voilà tout
cas je me couche
j'ai ça dans ma tête vous vous levez le
matin à servir au galop après une
bataille judiciaire de dix ans le couple
gadin n'a pas d'autre choix que de faire
appel à la générosité des gens ils ont
lancé il ya quelques semaines une
cagnotte en ligne qui rassemble déjà
plus de 2000 euros leur ultime espoir
réside désormais dans la cour européenne
des droits de l'homme qu'ils pourraient
saisir prochainement